uh let's get let's start with the issue
of the coronavirus and the response in
particular schools reopening uh they
reopen
uh monday uh for ccsd at unlv
you've been an advocate we've talked
before about you know you want to get
schools and businesses open pretty much
asap in a safe manner
in your mind how should schools
reopen period
obviously a safe responsible way
and as you know i have five children i
have one on the way
sarah's actually pregnant with number
six and
you know it's just very very frustrating
to me because
you have kids that can go to private
schools
and they can actually go back to school
and then you have the kids in the public
school
that can't go back it's
it's very very frustrating my son um
you know i have a very very mixed
diverse dependent upon what
our child's need because i can't afford
to send them all to
private school um one of my
my son uh one of my sons went back
yesterday
and they had all the they wore masks
they had their desks six five six feet
apart
uh and it was safe and and i feel safe
sending my child
back my frustration is that
well the parents that can't afford to
send their kids to private schools right
now
what are they going to do they're going
to have to hire tutors
okay they're going to have to hire uh
daycare and then they have to make a
decision
do i hire them or do i go back to work
it's not fair that's why i am the
biggest
advocate for school choice and i've said
it before i don't care if you're black
white red green male female
rich poor you know every child deserves
a right to a great education and that's
another reason why we have to get school
choice out there
and look at it look at it right now in
regards to school choice
you know what's so frustrating
about this whole school choice thing and
i'm such an advocate and
my opponent is so far against it
but it's kind of weird that my opponent
suzy lee
she sends her kids to a 65 000 a year
boarding school
so she believes in parents choice
but she doesn't believe in parents
choice for the folks here
in nevada and in cd3 it's very very
frustrating
well i want to try and stay specific to
the issue of the coronavirus um
you're talking about the the differences
in getting kids back to school which is
can't really be argued because there is
differences depending on what school
charter schools etc
we in two colleges notre dame and uh unc
out in north carolina they tried to go
back to school acknowledging that's
higher education
or we're not talking necessarily apples
to apples here
and immediately they went right back to
to online education it didn't work for
them
why would it work in nevada well you're
talking about two different states
well but but just broadly i mean we're
talking about the coronavirus here they
did
try and start other public schools
around the country
why is nevada different why should why
would it work here and
in some states they work some states
they don't but
they're not even giving an option to
send our kids back
originally since lack wanted to send
them back three days
and then you know then home two days and
that makes no sense that's that goes
exactly back to what you're saying
if you could send them in three days you
know why is that safer than
letting them go back you know obviously
five days
you know we do need to put in
precautions
we want to make sure that our teachers
are safe
we want to make sure that our children
are safe
and that's obviously number one priority
but
right now they should have the option
and if a parent feels safe enough to
send their child back
to school they can and if they don't
feel safe
that's not a problem it was like my son
my son broke his leg
he broke his leg okay he couldn't go
back to school
so he had to do distance learning we
already have it in effect
so i think it should be up to the
parents final question on this
do you think there should be some sort
of a benchmark for
um it's let's say the kids go back to
school should there is there a threshold
where
if cases get too high or there's too
many uh
issues of illnesses in schools let's
hope there isn't but let's just
hypothetically
is there a threshold where you say okay
yes we do need to close schools yes we
do need to close businesses
yes we do need to to shut down again
that would just depend you know
theoretically because that's what you're
saying
a lot of random you know theoretically
obviously if we had an influx and every
child
got it yeah or you know a huge
percentage of children did
then obviously we wouldn't want our kids
in harm's way
i don't want to put my children in our
way of course
um let's talk about the recovery from
the from the coronavirus um we've seen
stimulus packages go through there's
another one they're talking about on
capitol hill right now it's kind of
stuck between congress and the senate if
you're elected
to uh congress um
what do you think would be the right
solution to trying
to uh help the country recover i'll tell
you what the wrong solution is
i'll tell you the wrong solution is that
when we had the cares act
and we were trying to get that through
where was my opponent susie lee
she went on vacation for for two weeks
her nancy pelosi nancy pelosi was
showing off her ice cream in her freezer
okay we need folks that will go back to
to dc we need leaders that will go back
stay there
and get things accomplished and right
now we don't have that
okay i am so you're gonna get me fired
up here you're going to be i don't want
to do the wwe deal but this is an issue
that i am very very fired up about
the fact that president trump had to
come in and sign an executive order
for 400 to get folks money
to give folks money because they
couldn't pay their mortgage
they couldn't pay their rent you know
they were losing their 401ks or their
retirements
you know this is unacceptable and the
fact that the president had to come in
and do it
when susie lee wouldn't come to the
table and said she came back here
you know where has she been she was out
front lobbying at the post office
you you say the that the president had
to sign this executive order but
they the house has passed another
measure and it has been stalled between
the house and
so it's not as though whether it's
congresswoman lee or any other person in
congress republican
things have happened there and if you
were serving things would have happened
there too so
is that a fair um accusation to make
that your opponent isn't involved when
the congress did in fact pass a new
measure
it's just that the senate won't take it
up in there and things have stalled
in between the two houses
here's the issue we need folks
to work together okay
we already know suzy lee's record she
already voted 98
with nancy pelosi
and aoc the far left radical regime
we don't have folks working together
okay that's what's
different about me i'm not a politician
okay i am a voice for the people to get
things done
so when i go to washington dc i'm going
to spend
more than three quarters of my time with
the other side with democrats
understand what their issues are and if
they want this this this and this
then i can go back to my caucus and say
hey look they want this this and this
and i understand
i see where they're coming from and we
can give them this and this but we need
this and this
and that's the problem right now with
washington d.c
folks aren't working together and that's
what i'm going to bring to the table
and i'm going to be that voice for the
people here in nevada
that will fight for them and protect
them
let's talk about transparency uh the and
i have a feeling i know what your answer
is going to be on this but with regards
to the initial ppp
loans and with regards to any other sort
of stimulus or recovery package moving
forward
are we as the public aware
enough of what's included
in any sort of government package and
what would you do in congress
to make sure we are aware of what's
actually getting through
well it is transparency and that's one
of the major
issues here you know folks
were out there and i get these so does
susie lee were
what each side is fighting for but it
doesn't get out there
you know it doesn't get down to break
down exactly what it is
you know transparency is so very very
important
right now with this next this next uh
stimulus uh
plan that's coming out because
not only do they don't know where you
know folks don't know where this money's
going to right now we have
you know folks getting 600 they're
getting more than
they were making before and and that's
an issue that we
really need to take our time on and
understand
but at the same time let's not wait for
two weeks
i mean transparency is a major major
issue let me talk about
transparency for a second let's talk
about
transparency and the 5.6 million dollars
that suzie lee lobbied for
she took for her and her husband's
business
she lied about it and then when
when asked if any democrat leaders
informed her that it was self-serving
what did she say nope no idea what
you're talking about
but then when msnbc msnbc of all
stations called her out on it she said
okay well okay i did it
i did it nobody wants a leader that's
self-serving
that will go to washington dc and fill
their own pockets
during coven coven
i i would just say though and
we've spoken with congresswoman lee uh
specific to that issue um
she would she has said broadly that it
wasn't just her husband's company that
that was involved this was broadly for
the casino industry
does that soothe your she fired
a ton of her employees before
she got that money uh sooner than
heck we needed it we have a restaurant
we're hurting we didn't fire any of our
employees
okay and what did she do
she lobbied for it she sent a letter to
secretary
ninja and and asked for it specifically
and then she got it and then where did
that money go it didn't even go to the
the businesses here in nevada she sent
it to outside businesses
the end of the day it comes down to you
know you you have somebody do you
and and i know this because i've talked
to republicans
democrats independents libertarians they
don't
want a multi-millionaire
self-serving politician going up to
washington
to fill their own pockets we can't have
that
we can't have it um
how are you in congress how would you be
able to ensure that here in nevada
the state the industries the people get
what they need
to recover and how are the people not
getting that now with
congressman lee well
i'll tell you right now we which is
it's a broader topic but
we're having a hard time processing
unemployment
checks right now
how do you think when we have this
mail-in ballot
how the post office is going to be able
to process
all these hundreds and thousands
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands
of ballots it's not going to happen
these are these are glitches these are
major major issues
right that the far left radical
regime is is implementing that
it's not helpful we need we need
like i said transparency accountability
efficiency
if we can get those in the next bill and
it's not by
sitting here at home lobbying in front
of a post office it's about being in
washington dc
talking to the folks working with them
making sure that we
get people to work together and make
sure we get the right
amounts of money to the people the right
way but that's not going to happen when
our congresswoman is here
and she's not working for us
just very quickly this isn't necessarily
specific to congresswoman lee but
broadly you're talking a lot about
reaching across the aisle you're not the
first politician to say that or
i shouldn't say you're not the first
candidate to say that i know you don't
like being called a politician
how do you plan to start a conversation
working across the aisle when you refer
to democrats as the radical regime or
some of them anyway
how about something radical you're
saying the far far left right
i understand that but i'm just saying
like just to finish
how do you start a conversation or how
do you have a conversation
when that is the sort of
category that you or many of your
supporters might put the other political
party in
doesn't that make it doesn't that put
you on the make it hard to have that
conversation to begin with
no because i'm talking about the far
left radical regime i'm talking about
the the aoc's
okay the the true swamp of
of of the democrat party i know that the
moderates
they want to work together i know that
we're in a moderate district cd3 is a
moderate district
and they want to work with both sides
the independents
libertarians democrats republicans we
want to work together
the folks we know we can work together
you know are these moderate democrats
that
you know that want to try to get things
accomplished
and those are the folks that i want to
work with i'll work with them every day
switching gears we were talking before
we started about some of your recent
endorsements uh
law enforcement endorsements
particularly the the main union for
metro police and other law enforcement
agencies
uh here in southern nevada there's been
a lot of talk about police reform bills
both on the state level and on the
national level
what what does police reform look like
to you
well in regards to the endorsement you
know like i said i'm honored
humbled to to to be supported
by i think it's 23 or 24 different
associations
over a hundred i believe it's a hundred
different organizations ten thousand
police officers
right now in our district people want to
be protected
okay they want somebody to step up and
be their voice and
make sure they're protected and like i
said you know earlier
the fact is is they pulled that
endorsement from suzy lee
because she's not interested in
protecting
she's interested in well
other things hanging out at home for two
weeks
uh when we're working on the cares act
but
you know this is a time in my district
my district right now i talk to these
folks they don't want less police
officers
they want more police officers they want
to make sure
that if there's an issue they have a
police officer there
to protect him and
you know we we are in a situation right
now where
like i said earlier i do not believe in
federal overreach
i believe that the state and and local
level leaders should be making these
you know these rules i don't believe
that a congressman
in maryland should be making the laws
for our state here in nevada we have
many many different issues so
in regards uh to
abuse reform like i said earlier my
father was a police officer
and i respect our police officers i
stand with our police officers i'll
never defund them
and i want to make sure that they go out
there and they can protect the community
with everything they need to come back
home to their families
just real quickly you mentioned
something about um federal law
enforcement and
i think you were referring to or maybe
you weren't uh
issues of federal what has happened
recently federal law enforcement going
into places up in portland
chicago i think milwaukee other cities
around the country do you then not
support the president's plan on that
we are in scary times okay like i said
earlier i have six children
and one on the way this is a very very
scary time to bring a baby
into this world we have we have people
trying to burn down
rioters trying to burn down buildings
burn down
churches shooting police officers
like we had right here in nevada right
here in las vegas
in the head okay police officers
around the country being shot and killed
and we need to protect these folks
okay there's a difference between
protesting
and rioting okay
we can't have rioting if it happened
here
if it happened in your your backyard
would you want protection
because i would
um i'd like to address something that
your opponent has addressed herself in
an interview that we did a couple of
weeks ago uh this is
it's a personal issue for you uh calls
to 9-1-1 back in 2018 no charges no
arrests we've yet you've talked about
this i believe
not not too long ago you previously had
an arrest you went into a deferment
program
democrats have made it a part of their
campaign against you
can you address those charges for the
constituents in
in your district and
help articulate if your past
might affect your judgment in the future
if you're elected to congress
specific maybe to police reform or
broadly other issues
yeah absolutely the problem
with washington dc is mutzling
you're gonna take whatever you got and
you're gonna throw it up against the
wall
here you see what sticks right
the fact is is i'm gonna say this
bluntly
and loud and clear i've never been
convicted of a crime
in my life okay
now in regards to the 911 calls
it happened my wife and i we got into a
verbal argument
okay and nothing came of it
there was no arrests no convictions and
later on that day my wife and i went out
to dinner
and we're happily married i love my wife
i wouldn't be here right now without her
and uh we have we have a baby on the way
we are very very happily married and i'm
blessed
to to have such an amazing wife in
regards to
um any other incidents you're talking
about
then you can go to the review journal i
gave all of them i gave all of my apple
research to them
i said here you go and it's and if you
want to read it you can read it it's
online it's online
it shows dan rhodeiver was never
convicted of a crime in his life
so if they want to throw that at me if
that's all
susie lee has to throw at me
compared to somebody who decided to
let's say take 5.6 million dollars in
ppp loans
and lie about it or let's say
sell off all your stock the day you
found out in a closed meeting with
uh with uh with congress
and then the following week buy up all
the
the best big box grocery stock and other
pharmaceutical socks that skyrocketed
if they if she wants to throw that at me
it doesn't really matter because the
facts are
people are going to see through it
they're going to see that they have a
self-serving
politician that went to enrich herself
and make more money for her family
than trying to work for the families out
there and that's what i will do when i'm
your congressman
i will be that voice i will fight for
you and i will be there for you
and and just to be clear i'm personally
not terribly interested in mud slinging
from
anyone either i think what i'm trying to
just
get at and i've asked other politicians
this too is just and you've even
addressed this with regards to your
opponent the idea of your
personal life impacting potentially
judgment in office and my question is
simply
specific to this issue involving that
aspect of your past
will that affect your judgment in some
fashion
moving forward if there are issues
involving
uh i don't know
i'm just saying this is potential issues
let's just say police reform domestic
violence issues
other issues that can be addressed
legislatively
does your experiences in the past affect
your judgment of that moving forward
well my experience in the in the past
being a former wwe pro wrestler
they owning a number of small businesses
very successful businesses
going to law school understanding the
law
and bringing that to congress absolutely
will help
everything that i've been through is a
life lesson
okay things that the negative things
that you're saying that happened
when i was in college okay
life lessons like i said i've never been
convicted of a crime in my life
but the fact is is have i learned from
everything across the board
throughout all these years you know
from from high school all the way
through to law school
having all these opportunities that's
what i'm going to bring i'm a regular
person i'm a regular guy i'm a family
man
i own a small business i'm not like you
know these average pilot you know
pretty much you know a lot of these
politicians including susie lee i'm not
a multi-millionaire
you know i am different and i'm
passionate
about helping nevada and fighting for
them and having a voice
for these people for these people out
here that need it right now they need it
more than ever they need to be able to
to get money back in their pocket they
need to be able to go back to work and
after this coded situation
we're going to need to bring jobs back
here we're going to need to bring
manufacturing back here
we can't rely on other countries god
forbid what happens
what happens if we have this again if if
another scenario happens like this again
do we want to rely on other countries
for ventilators and
and pharmaceutical
pharmaceuticals no let's bring those
jobs back here
let's bring them back to nevada's third
district let's get folks trained let's
get them back to
to schools to technical schools so they
can come out
and they they can have little
electricians a license or an hvac
license or a nurse my daughter
i just put her in a technical school for
nursing 18 months
but these are the things we need to grow
to prosper to rebuild our economy
how do you do that money just prop up
let's say uh the casinos
on the strip to make sure that they
don't all go under and
uh they're here when the restrictions
are lifted
what do you what can you do it's for any
politician it's a challenging situation
it's going to be extremely challenging
it's going to be extremely extremely
challenging
so what do you do get everybody back to
work i mean right now
we have four i don't know how many
casinos that went dark we got a lot of
them
you know we have um
huge numbers of people leaving the state
because we're the entertainment capital
of the us you know that's what we thrive
on
and we just we need jobs we need
we we need to if we bring back
manufacturing
it creates jobs i talked today when i
got the
uh abc contractors endorsement
i talk to them about it and what do they
need the most
when we start rebuilding because we will
we will rebuild
i will not give up on that i will fight
and fight and fight and fight
to protect us but when that time comes
we need folks to be able to be properly
trained to get out there
and start working again and that's right
try to cut you off sorry there um final
question uh i
do want to ask one question about
immigration um
there have been efforts in the white
house to get rid of daca
you've watched it as closely as i have
and we've seen the effects here in las
vegas
would you be in favor of passing any
kind of legislation to either
well to get rid of daca period and then
broadly
what needs to happen with immigration
what would you do as a congressman
on the border that is either a
continuation of what's been going on
under president trump or maybe something
slightly different
down the line
i get this question a lot in regards to
immigration
in regards to protecting our our borders
and it is an immigration issue
and there's a lot of different ideas out
there how to fix this
okay as of right now
when i get there i will listen i will
listen to both sides
all right we have laws in effect right
now
and before we start putting in new laws
we need to we need to
you know follow those laws
in regards to the border right now
i'll say it again i have five children i
got one on the way
i'm worried about you know obviously
drug smugglers
and sex traffickers and and uh and
cartel members
coming over i don't want them coming to
nevada i don't want
uh i don't want people coming out here
and pushing drugs on my kids
you know or sex traffickers it's
grotesque
and you know president trump he came in
you know he wanted to protect our
borders susie lee she voted against it
she voted against protecting our borders
i don't care if you're a republican
democrat independent libertarian
nonpartisan doesn't matter who you are
you want to protect your borders you
want to protect
the folks here and she voted against it
she voted against protecting
the people in nevada so these are these
are things that
when we get to washington dc
and we will win i know we're going to
win
these are issues that we're going to
have to look at the big picture sit down
and work together on it
so just to be clear i'm hearing things
that you're concerned about and and
first and this last question
frustrations with with congresswoman lee
but i'm not hearing a solution or at
least
a desire to follow the existing
plans from the white house
so do you have any of those i believe
that there is an immigration issue
absolutely but do you believe in some
kind of an immigration solution
absolutely what would that be the the
solution is going to be when we get
there
i want to look at everything across the
board because right now
both sides are literally in gridlock
they're not working together
on it you know the lines take it takes a
long time
to get through the immigration system
does it need to be fixed
absolutely but uh do the folks that
want to you know come over from other
countries
you know you know jump in line so
we need to work together on it we have a
lot of great folks that are here
that worked hard right and this is
something that we need to work on
together when we get there
all right i'm out of questions i
appreciate your time dan good to see you
again
hey good luck to you i'll talk to you
later all right god bless the bad and
god bless america
take care yourself